all right talk to me about inflation 6.2
cpi yesterday do you believe these
numbers no actually the numbers are
worse first of all we know what's going
on with rent right with owner's
equivalent rent which the government
uses in replace of actual rent and
actual rents are rising four times
faster than what you know owner's
equivalent rent and of course home
prices don't even make it into the cpi
at all and they're way up so people who
want to buy houses you know they're
looking at even bigger price increases
than the people who want to rent them
but i think a lot of the other you know
numbers are massaged the way they are
you know put through the the methodology
for computing the the uh the number you
know they they substitute things if
things go up they they don't count them
the whole system is rigged to give you a
low number and despite the rigging we
still have almost seven percent if you
annualize the first 10 months of this
year uh and then you know it's almost
seven percent inflation uh mentioned by
the cpi so even the government number is
bad but reality is much worse
when you think about the inflation
numbers themselves it's very obvious
that things like food gasoline etc are
all uh exploding one of the takeaways
that i had from the cpi numbers was that
whether food at home or food out of the
home was both up over five percent how
do you think about the basket of goods
in terms of the things that people spend
a lot of money on rent food uh utilities
versus maybe some of the more um kind of
uh infrequent type of goods that they
may consume it feels like the things
that i really care about those are
actually up pretty materially and then
there's a bunch of stuff that maybe i
care maybe i don't but but i just use
them less frequently yeah if you measure
the cost of living if you actually look
at the basket of goods and services that
people are buying i think that basket is
going up faster than some of the goods
that people may not buy at all you know
or may just buy
once in a while you know if you look at
let's say a laptop computer how often do
you buy a new laptop i mean maybe every
few years i mean some people wait longer
than that they make do with the one they
have but you're buying groceries every
week right you're buying gasoline every
week you're paying your electric bill uh
so there are a lot of things that you
know the higher prices you got to pay
some of the things if the prices are
down a little bit you may not even be
buying them because you're spending so
much money on the things you need you
don't even have that much money left
over for some of the other things that
you want when you also think about
things like employment how do you settle
in your mind that there is 11 million
open jobs and nearly 5 unemployment
number like how are those two things
possible to be operating at the exact
same time well either the people who are
unemployed don't want those jobs
or they're not qualified for those jobs
but that is a problem in the economy
when you have a lot of job openings that
workers neither want nor qualify for
and so the question is why are they not
qualified and why don't they want them
and i think there are different answers
to those questions but certainly one
reason that people may not want jobs is
maybe they got a better deal from the
government they uh they'd rather collect
benefits than collect a paycheck because
you have to work for the paycheck but i
also think there's a lot of young people
maybe they got a lot of cryptocurrency
and they're just trading or they're
trading stocks on their robinhood app
and you know it's a bubble and they
think they're geniuses and maybe they're
making enough money just trading crypto
or or stocks and they figure they don't
need a job